e
envoyé spécial,
Philippe Leblanc.
- L'enlèvement du maire
de Melns le sud
de l'Ukraine, et le fait que
des équipes de journalistes
britanniques et néerlandais
aient été la cible de tirs
depuisde l'évasion,
selon Reporters sans frontières,
illustrent la nécessité plus que
jamais d'avoir une presse libre,
une presse qui peut effectuer
son troute sécurité
pour départager le vrai du faux
en temps de guerre ici, donc,
en Ukraine.
C'est pour ça qu'il y a
la c ce centre pour
la liberté de presse à Lviv,
dans l'ouest de l'Ukraine.
On va fournir de l'équipement
de protection aux journalistes,
donc v-balles,
casques et aussi des trousses
de premiers soins, et surtout,
des séances de formation
pour les médias ukrainiens.
Les journalistes ukrainiens
qui n'étaient pas nécessairement
préparés, selon Reporters sans
frontières, à devenir du jour
au lendemain des reporters
de guerre dans leur propre pays.
On peut écouter le secrétaire
général de Reporters sans
frontières, à qui j'ai parlé
aujourd'hui.
CHRISTOPHE DELOIRE, sec. général
Reporters sans frontières
- Pour l'instant, on n'est
pas du tout dans la situationdes
tués en Irak, des dizaines
et des dizaines tués en Syrie.
Mais quand on regarde
ce qui s'est passé au cours
de ces dernières semaines, quand
on voit certaines des pratiques
de l'armée russe, on ne peut
qu'être extrêmement inquiets
pour les journalistes ukrainiens
et pour les journalistes
étrangers, qui sont extrêmement
nombreux à couvrir ce conflit.
Ce ne sont pas des reporters
qui sont allés à la guerre,
c'est la guerre est venue à eux.
- Sur place, il y aura aussi
accès à un centre de travail
pour les médias. Donc on aura
branchement à Internet, accès
à différentes sources
d'informations qui sont fiables
parce que l'autre volet
de ce centre de la liberté
de presse, c'est de combattre
la désinformation, qui est
très présente ici, en Ukraine.
Évidemment, avec les médias
russes qui sont tombés dans
la propagande, selon Reporters
sans frontières, et aussi
selon les différentes sources
d'informations pas toujours
fiables qu'on voit souvent
retweetées ou parmi
les publications sur Facebook,
donc on veut s'attaquer
à cette désinformation-là qui
est très présente sur les médias
sociaux. Mais Reporters sans
frontières insiste que c'est
le travail des journalistes,
ussi des cussi des cussi des cus
de bien s'informer. On peut
écouter le secrétaire général.
- Chaque citoyen a un rôle
à jouer en tant qu'électeur,
t qu'acteur démocratique
pour lutter contre
la désinformation.
- Ce centre de presse a été
établi à Lviv, dans l'
de l'Ukraine, parce que c'est
devenu le centre, la base de
travail, en fait, d'organismes
humanitaires, mais aussi de
nombreux journalistes étra
qui peuvent travailler quand
même en toute sécurité ici
et planifier des déplacements,
par exemple vers Kiev
et Marioupol, des endroi
où les combats font rage
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Lviv, en Uk